and we are now joined by magnus carlsen
congratulations on a fantastic ending to
the quarterfinals
thank you so much tell us about those
two blitz game how happy are you with
your
play here um
i'm happy of course uh but uh
i think it was more of a question of him
not
playing it to anything close to his
abilities in in the blitz
um so i i didn't really
have to have to do too much apart from
not you know uh putting something on pre
uh seeing as i was winning after the
opening in the first game and
in the second game i just had to put my
pieces on decent squares and
not blunder but no obviously uh
very satisfying oh yeah and magnus you
actually
lost the first game of today with white
how did you psych yourself up to bounce
back from that
oh it was unpleasant obviously um
but i i did have this experience against
him
another another day that or or
on many many other days it's felt like
when he's got the first win that he
he has a tendency to maybe tighten up a
little bit
and be a bit nervous uh so i was hoping
that was going to happen today as well
so magnus heading into semi-finals so
what are you sort of taking away from
these quarter-finals regarding your own
play um
no bio play um
it was okay there were some good moments
some definitely some bad moments
as well um
[Music]
but i do feel that while
i can obviously play better i feel like
i'm sort of into
into the rhythm now uh and
um i got a i got a series with wake up
call here in the
in the preliminaries um and
the the quarterfinals were just a
continuation of
of that really that there were never any
easy moments and like
right at the end that's the only time i
actually led
um which is actually what happened
against him in the
in the tour finals as well um so i i
definitely feel ready for
for more uh more fights now yeah
yeah and talking of more fights you're
facing timor rajabov in the next round
what are your thoughts on that matchup
certainly very very very interesting
last time out against him was very cagey
and i i've essentially
only had one chance to win which which i
took and he had a couple of chances to
um to at least put serious some pressure
on me that
he didn't take so i'm ex i'm expecting a
fairly different match from what we what
we had here
uh but um potentially just as tight
um yeah that was the court funds in the
new in chess classic
only one game ending up with a win in
this semi-final we had
six out of eight game in the rapid
ending with
with win so uh is it possible to do
something like that
against timor or is it just his style
impossible to
to get all those wins yeah i think it's
hard to
to crack him that often to be fair um
i think this match will be
more about you know getting getting the
first strike and then you'll be
be a uh huge favorite uh i don't i don't
think we'll
we'll be seeing comebacks in in the same
same way in this one
i could be wrong yeah of course well
magnus
congratulations on a fantastic ending to
today and good luck in the semis
thank you so much and uh obviously as
well
uh thanks to ikara as well for making it
a great great match it's always
so always a pleasure um
to to play these these matches against
them and that they
they are never boring definitely we
agree with you there
thanks magnus thank you